yeah she's a legend she's i i tell her  she's uh i've never seen it so you know  we're in such a weird time right 650  television shows 950 movies last year we  don't  like what she's doing is extraordinary  she's hysterical yet i could just name  three movies that is some of the best  dramatic performances i've ever seen  emily being the best of them maybe black  bear that's such a rarity i can only  name very few actors phil hoffman comes  to mind and robin williams and people  that do drama and comedy seamlessly you  know and she is doing that there's just  a very few and i know of course  everybody's like yeah but not at that  level of course give her a moment yeah  just you know but it's like when you're  doing that seamlessly when you're funny  and you're knocking it out apart  dramatically i mean we gotta stop and  pause for a second and say that's a  rarity